but do we feel that we know how to get
financial freedom out yeah absolutely
love this cause I love skip my hands
dirty and actually looking for
properties myself doing all the math see
using the formulas and just call it over
amazing deals it was great being able to
now go away and be able to know exactly
what I'm going to buy or something I've
just on a six hour round trip and where
was it worth there I couldn't miss
anything of the day all of it doers
not learners not getting information -
because chickens thousands of pounds
just below the house yeah we've got an
awesome opportunity here it's from the
research that we've done rooms are
letting out at very very conservative
350 so with that in mind we've got 107
percent return on investment potential
here he's got three rooms and
it's a tiny house that doesn't look like
it needs anything doing to it as well so
I'll just make the call get your great
value for your money so I would
definitely recommend it definitely I'm
glad I came
Thank You Samuel what do to invest with
67% oh my goodness
I was quite cynical when I first
attended SR my childhood wealth manager
and I've been really pleasantly
surprised with his professional approach
to matters and most importantly about
the positive returns on investment that
are available through proper
professional property investors so
thanks Sam
of course following up with you very
shortly awesome you won't find nothing
bad the information you get on property
investing I'm looking to move forward
now and I can see myself
freedom setting up my family lovely for
the future everything will be good at
night and I'm motivated and excited yeah
let's go no money some of us have got no
money but we still feel we can do this
yeah yes just when we feel we can make
fast money boy saw some properties yeah
yeah absolutely I mean high return
investment
although the highest return invest will
be had in the room we're having great
time if you found we're doing a killer
doing really cool one oh yeah come on
tell us the figures my mind has exploded
it was so very straightforward
there was nothing complicated about I
wish I'd found about this a property
course a few years ago and if you only
do one thing I recommend that you do
this course yes fantastic course great
content Britain thanks very much